Speaker 1: Let's see.
Where do we want to go next?
Let's try.
Let's go north of the border.
Let's go to Alex from Quebec.
Speaker 3: Hi, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can be on venue.
Speaker 3: Merci beaucoup.
I'm actually a first-time caller.
And before the pandemic in Quebec, the the
government had promised electoral reform away
from first past the post and into mixed member
proportional representation system.
Sure.
But among the advocates of electoral reform,
there was a big debate between those who wanted
proportional representation and those who
preferred a preferential voting system.
Justin Trudeau actually was more of an advocate
of the second option, while the provincial
government preferred the first option.
And I was just wondering what was your preference
between the two?
Speaker 1: Well, I, you know, I always hesitate
to weigh in specifically about questions in
front of other countries because I just don't
feel as if I'm as well-informed as I could
be or should be really to be commenting.
But I've talked over the years about a number
of different reforms to how we do our elections
that I would welcome.
I would love a proportional representation
system, big picture, because it could be a
way for third parties to make inroads in the
United States.
The risk, of course, is you get five percent
white supremacists or something crazy, and
that's something that that would have to be
dealt with.
Then we would have to think about that.
But I think proportional representation, especially
in the U.S., where this two party duopoly
is a complete and total mess, would be an
interesting thing.
Switching away from first past the post to
something like single transferable vote or
one of the many different ranked choice voting
systems that don't have some of the problems
that we've identified in a few of the systems
would also be very much welcome.
A combination of the two is something that
I would be open to.
I welcome that, and in the U.S., I've talked
about a lot in the context of Canada.
It seems more appropriate to ask someone who's
been following the Canadian discussion.
Speaker 3: Well.
In my honest opinion, yes.
Everyone just advocates for the reform that's
advantageous them generally, for example.
Yeah.
Justin Trudeau leads a centrist party, so
of course he will prefer a preferential voting
system.
If he ends up against a right wing candidate,
he'll get the wing vote.
And if he ends up against a left wing candidates,
he'll get the right wing vote.
Whereas in Quebec, where the main issue has
been nationalist, not in the sense of like
white nationalists in America, but nationalist
as wanting more autonomy for the province,
wanting to protect the French language and
so on.
Of course, yeah.
Usually, these parties have split the votes
between left and the right wing nationalist,
allowing for, well, parties who aren't that
to win more seats than they should have.
And so Quebec nationalists, of course, prefer
a proportional voting system to increase their
representation.
Speaker 1: Yeah, on that on that front, what
what are the rules right now in terms of the
signage in Quebec?
Is it that they the signs have to be only
in French or it has to be French first and
larger?
Speaker 3: Well, in the 70s, they tried to
make it only and the French.
And the Supreme Court of Canada said you're
not allowed to do that.
That's infringing on freedom of speech.
OK.
And so today it's predominantly French.
That means you can put it in English, but
the font has to be smaller than the French
understood, I think.
I think there's an exception in the native
communities where you are allowed to have
signed the Jews only and like Inuit or you're
on the right stuff like that because, yeah,
we want to protect French, but we don't want
to like and native languages.
Speaker 1: Are you day to day?
What's the how much French versus English
are you speaking?
Is it ninety ten?
Is it?
Speaker 3: I almost don't.
Well, I live in a rural region so far away
from Montreal, where in Montreal you need
English?
Yes.
But outside of that, you don't really need
to.
I only learned to speak English at 14.
OK?
So it really wasn't a necessity in my day-to-day
life.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Understood.
All right.
Very good.
Fascinating to hear about what's going on
in Quebec.
I appreciate the call.
Speaker 3: All right, thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right, thank you.
Really great topics today.
Really, really great topics.
Let's speak to oh, I don't know, how about
is this?
Is this Jake from Massachusetts?
Hold on.
Is it?
Oh, no, it's do not call on.
Did not want me to call.
I'm sorry, but wow, I apologize.
Somebody was just they left a note saying,
Don't call on me, and it just looked so interesting
that I had to go with it.
Let's go to Michael from Berlin.
Michael, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hey, David.
Yes, thank you here.
Pleasure.
I'm actually Berlin in New Jersey.
Oh, well, I don't have an accent.
All right.
Speaker 1: Well, actually, you do have an
accent, but it's a Jersey accent.
Speaker 4: Yes.
Yes.
Thank you.
I visited Germany 13 times, though, because
my grandparents are from Austria, so I'm a
first generation Austrian American.
Speaker 1: Now let me let me inquire about
that.
You went to Germany 13 times because your
parents are from Austria.
Why not go to Austria?
I mean,
Speaker 4: I'm sorry to clarify your Frankfurt
airport and.
Went from Frankfurt to Vienna, Austria.
Got it.
And so that was about 13 times through Frankfurt.
So I'm a little nervous this the first time
I've ever called any show, you're doing great
so far.
This is actually on my bucket list.
So and that's one of the things I do.
Well, what's on your bucket list?
Speaker 1: Oh, I don't.
I don't have any I don't ever think about
in those terms.
Unfortunately, I am.
I couldn't.
Yeah, I don't have a bucket list.
Speaker 4: OK, well, my bucket.
I just wanted to give an example.
My bucket list would be to travel the United
States.
I'm into endurance events and I would love
to go for a distance bike tour of the US and
just meeting people and discussing, you know,
meeting with different people and talking
about, you know, other things, local things,
you know, just learning, learning from different
cultures in the U.S. and maybe some of the
technocracy how we can help our our democracy
get along.
Excellent.
Understand the process of just getting involved
in local politics.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
That seems like a worthy thing.
Speaker 4: Well, I mean, you got leave of
absence, so that will take me like a month
or a couple of months to do.
Speaker 1: Oh yeah, I would set aside some
time for that.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I like the shout out to Egbert
as well, who was from Vienna.
He was a carver.
And he hasn't called in for a while and I've
really enjoyed his is, you know, when he called
in.
All right.
Speaker 1: Very good shout out to eg Bert
from Austria.
I so appreciate the call.